What do you do
before you shoot a scene
to get into...
I just drink juice and
eat food. I don't really...
I don't really--
I don't know man.
I don't think about it much.
You're just
naturally talented.
He's a natural.
When you think about it,
that's when things
start to go wrong.
I don't learn lines
on purpose.
Bun that.
So, this season,
you're not only an actor,
you're also an EP,
an executive producer.
So, what does that mean?
What do you do as an exec?
It means
I can write you out.
That's what it means.
It means...
D'you know what,
it means empowerment...
for us
because we can have
some, you know, impact
on the stories
that are gonna to be told
about the lives
that most of us on this...
D'you know what I mean,
on this platform have led,
d'you know what I'm saying?
You know,
the beauty of Top Boy is
that it represents
a certain people.
And I know myself 100%,
and Kane,
have come from that life,
d'you know what I'm saying?
So, who better
to tell those stories
or be a part
of shaping those stories
for the rest of the world
to see?
You know, we've been
involved in the scripts,
we've been involved
in like the journey
of you lot's characters,
not only our own characters
but kinda where you guys go.
It's good to have
that position,
it's good to be able to...
to just be a bit
more involved creatively
in what happens
with the show.
I got a link
to Spain and Morocco.
About to come through
with a big bit.
More money than you've seen
in your life, bro.
Do you wanna be a part of it
or what?
Part of it how?
By doing
what you always done.
Selling food.
Your food, yeah?
I guess it is, yeah.
My food.
From the first season,
that's when
I really wanted to be in it.
I saw Dris,
we were from the same...
How old were you then?
-Probably 14, 15.
-OK.
I see Dris in the show.
We're from the same area,
so I was like,
"Bro, you can't get man
in the show? Bro..."
Didn't really
work like that.
D'you know what I'm saying.
But then I heard
they were doing auditions
for the next season
that was coming.
I see one of my guys pull up
with his cousin,
his cousin's an actor,
he had an agent at the time,
everything.
I see him
just walking past all of us,
doing his thing and cut.
I was thinking: Is that
the power of an agent?
I need to find a way to get
an agent or something.
I didn't even
get to do the audition.
And then this time
came around...
Remember my cousin
telling me
she was like
yeah she heard
that there's
auditions for Top Boy
and I was like, "You sure?"
She said yeah,
so, I asked my agent
to keep her ears open.
She was like,
"I suggested you for it."
I was like, "Yeah?
A'ight. OK. Say no more",
you know what I'm sayin',
and then, yeah.
Today, there's so many
different routes to market.
Back in the day, you talked
about the agent thing,
it had to be an agent thing,
you had to have an agent.
"How do I get an agent
if I haven't done anything."
The answer was,
"I don't know".
You know, one of them ones.
But now, with the rise
in social media,
where people
like Des street casting,
there are
many different avenues
into the game.
I told some of my friends,
"You don't have to go
to drama school,
you don't have to have...",
you know?
You can do it yourself,
you can set up your camera
and learn a monologue
and record it yourself,
hit up an agency on a DM,
send it to them.
Shoot your shot.
We've had
some interesting stories
of how people
have got into the show
and I wanna hear yours
'cause I know you...
I heard
there was something to do
with a barber shop.
Yeah.
So, I remember
I was going back to school
and my hair was
just horrendous.
I'm in the barbers
and the barber
is doing some madness
to people's hair.
I'm seeing zig zags,
people's hairlines are back,
I'm thinking:
Yeah, you need to get out
because this is not it.
So, then,
as I was about to leave,
a woman came to us and said,
"Audition for Top Boy".
At first, I was thinking
she's not telling the truth,
she's just chatting
because Top Boy,
that's a long time ago,
so what's going on?
But then she was like,
"No, it's real.
I'll just write your name
down in my book
and I'll give you
a certain time
to come in
to a certain place."
I was like, "I might as well
'cause
I have nothing to do."
I went in and then, yeah...
The rest is history.
You're here.
So, I love those stories,
man.
Like, they touch me, man.
This season especially
has given
such an incredible platform
for all the female cast
to have
these dimensional characters
that have so much to them.
From the last season,
Lauryn starts off like,
"Ha ha, champagne, boys!",
all of that.
And then, towards the end,
it all goes terribly wrong
for her.
But I feel like this season,
it's just a series
of unfortunate events
again and again.
And the subject matter
and the storyline
was not something
I took lightly at all.
It was kind of interesting,
we were half filming Top Boy
during the pandemic,
domestic violence was
at an all-time high.
So, I actually
got in contact
with
a domestic violence charity
in order to speak to them
and help me navigate
how to, you know...
tell the truth
with my character
and what she goes through.
Curtis, please.
Can I have some privacy?
I'm only going in there
to try some things on.
Please.
No, she's right.
She needs her privacy.
Thank you.
I'll go with her.
Oh, yeah. Go on.
Come here.
What's wrong?
Baby, what's wrong?
Please, please,
I'm just so ashamed.
Look, I feel so ugly
and bloated
and I don't want anyone
seeing me like this.
It's only Vee.
Eh, you're beautiful to me.
To me?
-Did you just say that?
-What I meant was you're...
-What, I disgust you? Yeah?
-No.
Come here, come here.
Hey, it's all right.
Can I please be by myself?
-One minute, please?
-All right, just don't cry.
You go.
Please
can I have some money?
Although I've come
from a different background
to the characters
in the story,
I've been given
such an amazing storyline.
As someone
who came into the show
as a new person,
it showed me
for the first time
that it was a possibility
that I could be
in something like that.
To be honest,
the whole experience
was quite nerve-wracking.
I mean, I'm so lucky
that I had Saffron and Jazz.
Like,
they were so supportive.
Saffron,
we had loads of bants,
we had so many LOLs.
-Constant laughing.
-Yeah.
One of my first scenes was
kind of like a mad scene
that was so challenging.
I didn't really understand
any of the language,
it was so new to me to be,
like, in front of the camera
in such a different way.
It's so interesting,
you can do as many
acting classes as you want,
you can train
as much as you want
when you're at home,
but, actually,
being on set is the lesson.
I like your style.
It's not my style,
it's just me.
OK, well, I like you.
I think
you look really great.
That was your cue...
to say something
really nice,
preferably without me
having to prompt you.
I mean,
when Li said to me
she wanted to hook me up,
I wasn't expecting her
to look like you.
What's it like
being recognised
in the show?
Like, doing your own thing,
you're still at school.
Are girls running after you?
-No. No girls.
-Yeah, yeah.
I think, in general,
I still live a normal life
'cause I still live
with my mum.
However,
I am more recognised
in certain places
which I go.
More doors are open for me,
but, in general,
I try to keep to myself,
quiet,
and to focus on
what I need to do.
No, I saw you filming
a music video
in the middle of Shoreditch,
so I don't know
what you're talking about!
When you were there
like, "Ay".
I was like, "Is that Aaron?"
and you said, "You cool?"
and then
you went back to it.
No, that was my friend
who I was supporting.
-Yeah...
-But I think...
No, but, in general,
I do like to keep quiet
and just perfect
the art of acting, so...
In sixth form, I'm at home
trying to work on my accent
or doing auditions.
Looking back
on your Top Boy legacy,
what does all that
mean to you?
How does it feel
to be sat here today?
When we started this thing,
we didn't even know
it was gonna get made.
When I read
those first scripts
that Ronan wrote
and I see people
getting shot in their head
and fingers getting cut off
and all this stuff,
that stuff
had never been on TV before.
This life,
the story of this life
had never been told
in the way
that it was about to be told
at that moment.
Me and Kane would be on set
shooting scenes,
night shoots,
doing these crazy things,
actually looking
at each other feeling like:
Is this actually
going to get put out?
Are we wasting our time?
Are they gonna put this
on TV?
And to see
what it's grown into,
there was no point
where we sat there thinking:
This is going to be huge,
know what I'm sayin'?
We just didn't know
what the beast would be.
So, to be able
to sit back now,
see it on Netflix,
see it doing well
in the States and Europe.
-Billboards...
-Billboards and whatever.
Times Square.
Yeah. It's like...
It was no easy thing.
Why do you think Top Boy is
still relevant today?
I think it's relevant
'cause it depicts real life.
There's actually youths
that come
from a deprived community
that go through
these real-life situations.
It's important
that these stories are told
so people can get an insight
of how it actually is.
It's not senseless in a way,
everyone's doing something
for a reason,
everyone's trying to live
and survive,
everyone wants
a better life.
People thought
I was a wasteman
on the last one because
I missed with the shotgun.
Were you getting challenged
about that?
Everywhere I'd go,
"How could you let him
overpower you
with the shotgun?"
Yeah.